du zeigst viel wie das geht
oder soll ich sagen okay ich hallo die
samira hat ja schon die einleitung hier
gemacht heute möchte ich mit schritten
machen und zwar habe ich mir gedacht
dass ich dieses jahr ist erst mein
zweites video in diesem jahr dass ich
dieses jahr ein paar neue sachen macht
und mir ist dann ein gefallen und er
sagt uns dass wir so der neuen kategorie
machen könnten in der ich gekaufte
sachen selbst nach mache also in diesem
fall ist die milch schnitte und flash
hat er eine idee wie ich diese kategorie
nennen könnte also dekalb gekauft und
selbst gemacht finde ich jetzt ein
bisschen langweilig vielleicht fällt
euch daraus besseres ein
und dann können wir da gemeinsam
abstimmen heute möchte ich wie gesagt
die milchschnitten machen und habe mir
jetzt gedacht dass ich einen biss
beteilt macht als grund teig und dann
die füllung eben aus sahne mache ihr
wisst ja in der industrie wieder viel
mit verschiedenen stoffen gearbeitet und
wenn man sich jetzt beispielsweise
dieser milchschnitten kremann scheint so
jetzt besteht ja aus 2002 seien dünne
und ich habe mich jetzt aber dazu
entschlossen diesen tag etwas dicker zu
machen weil wir hatten schon eine
demoversion und jetzt und zwar jetzt
nicht so gut geschmeckt und wenn man
sich mal die creme anschaut die ich
jetzt ziemlich dick da drin
und die besteht wirklich aus milch also
die erste zutat weil die menschen
und ist wirklich mit die besteht zu 40
prozent aus milch natürlich sind da noch
stand auch noch fett zucker und alles
mit dabei aber die creme wird zb damit
stickstoff etwas aufgeschäumt und soeben
festgemacht und es kam eben im privaten
hausgebrauch gar nicht machen
deswegen wird es heute nur so eine
anlehnung und sonder variante es gibt ja
wirklich zahlreiche methoden und rezepte
und ich werde jetzt mal die zutaten für
den biskuit teig zeigen und zeigt euch
dann wie es weitergeht
und zwar braucht ihr 375 gramm zucker 50
gramm mehl hier ist ja wirklich die
frage ich gleich was es ist 25 gramm
kakaopulver 25 g speisestärke und lag
ganz kleine prise backpulver und es ist
wirklich eine ganz ganz einer prise nur
und wir brauchen noch einen schluck
wasser und zwar nie mit dafür
mineralwasser also wasser mit
kohlensäure
zuerst kommen jetzt die drei eier in die
rührschüssel
und jetzt beiden die eier verrührt und
werden richtig schön schaumig geschlagen
und dann kommt da noch der zucker mit
rein und das ganze wird solange gerührt
bis die masse richtig weiß cremig ist
der zucker kommt erst rein wenn das
whistler verrührt es okay
wenn ihr das dann habt gebt ihr die
trockene punkt hatten in so einem
kleinen sie dabei eben schon packen
deswegen sei es ebenso backpulver
stärken mehr so verhindert ihr nämlich
eine klümpchen bildung und da gebt ihr
gesprochen einem schluck wasser mit rein
dann wird es einmal mit schneebesen
unter meinen fertigen teig weil ich
jetzt in den backofen backen
ihr könnt das ganze natürlich auch auf
einem ganz normalen bug durch backen
ohne rahmen
allerdings habt ihr da nicht so schöne
gerade kanten sowie hier also wenn ich
das jetzt gleich hier tribeca habe ich
ja schon eine richtige rechteckige
platte und musste später noch halbieren
um zurechtschneiden und wenn ihr das
ganze auf einem backblech macht müsste
eben später am rand etwas wegschneiden
also deswegen finde ich es super wenn
man so über fragen sich mal zulegt kauft
man sich einmal dann müsste einfach
drauf achten dass er einen edelstahl
babbel nimmt davos rostfrei sein und
stabil und bei mir gibt's den ja in
kombination mit einer folie unter diesem
band black also dann müsste auch darauf
achten dass ihr mit den bug rahmen immer
auf diesem vorteil bach blech fakt weil
ansonsten der teig auslaufen kann und
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein ganz zu
setzen nützliches tool und zwar ist das
so backt einen kuchen tyler und zwar
kann man mit dem wie ihr seht die kuchen
verteilen also die markieren und hat
dann eben später gleichmäßiges stücke
wie diesen werde ich jetzt heute
arbeiten
da gibt es einmal die seite mit 30
flächen also mit quadraten und einmal
mit 24 und jetzt möchte ich natürlich
die mit 24 möchte länge
mit schnitten ich möchte jetzt nicht die
originale größe weil ich die per hand
schneiden müsste und so habe ich einfach
weiter sparen ist und wenn ihr jetzt
diesen bug haben nimmt könnte den auf
diese größe einstellen
das lege ich mir da drauf und schiebe
ich das einfach wieder so zurück und
dann habe ich jetzt mein raunen auf
diese größe eingestellt ganz einfach
und da fühle ich jetzt meinen tag rein
und jetzt wird es einmal hier schon
richtig verteilt
und ich verteile das ganz gerne noch mal
mit so einer tankkarte vor allen dingen
die mit dem kam dran weil dann hat man
das alles richtig schön gleichmäßig kann
dadurch war und auch den artikel
verlinkt ich euch natürlich in meiner
infobox unter dem video wo info steht
ich will es jetzt nochmal
nachkontrollieren mit der größe falls
sich jetzt beim verstreichen was
verändert hat aber passt alles so weit
und dieser tag wird jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad ober
und unterhitze gebacken
ich denke bei mir brauche etwa 15 bis 20
minuten nach 14 minuten mache jetzt auf
jeden fall meine stäbchen probe wobei es
bei so einem bühne teig aufgeht wenn ihr
einfach mal an die oberfläche gelangt
und wenn da nichts mehr an den fingern
hängen bleibt dann ist der teig durch
aber ich würde euch mit stäbchen der
tote natürlich raten weil das war nicht
so heiß ist und wer durch danach dann
das endergebnis zeigen mit stäbchen
probe meine ich folgen dass ihr nehmt
einen zahnstocher und sticht ihn hinein
und wenn da nichts mehr dran hängt dann
ist der tyczka oder ihr könnt wie gesagt
man an die oberfläche gelangen und bei
dem werk macht es jetzt dass der richtig
schön trocken ist und damit der teig
besser abkühlt nämlich diesen bug rahmen
weg und dazu vor ich nehme in der willi
palette entlang
das mache ich mit einer palette weil ich
ja nicht mehr in der messe auf dieser
folie schneiden sonst stehe folien
dann gebe ich da ein tuch drüber und
stürzt es einfach auf mein team und ich
sehe jetzt auch das ist ein fester bis
mittag also das solle jetzt ja keinen
locker mit kuchen werden weil ja die
milch-schnitte eben etwas fester ist in
der konsistenz und da gebe ich jetzt
einfach noch ein tuch drauf was das
abkühlen und das wird sollen etwa 10-15
minuten abgekühlt sein und da kann ich
weitermachen
mein tag ist jetzt schön abgekühlt und
ich werde jetzt erstmal die creme
vorbereiten und wie gesagt mache ich
heute eine creme aussage aber ihr könnt
genauso guten der kriege mit mascarpone
machen oder mit quark aber ich möchte es
jetzt einfach mal mit sahne machen und
zwar habe ich jetzt dafür 400 gramm
sahne zum stabilisieren nehme ich dann
ab herbst da könnt ihr natürlich auch
martin und ich habe zum beispiel helga
gelatine in meinem shop
da seht ihr hier oben das bild und den
link findet ihr unten hinter infobox
machst du mit dem quatsch dem park und
dafür verwende ich vier teelöffel seiner
partei am apparat ist nämlich davor teil
als bester ford verliert also das wird
sofort festessen schreiben pflanzlich
und ich habe keine wartezeiten
kühlschrank zum süßen verwenden sondern
zucker sirup das ist ein ganz einfacher
weißer zucker sirup gibt es meistens in
der getränkeabteilung bei den
alkoholischen sachen aber das ist nicht
altmodisch ist schon rainer flüssiger
zucker und ich habe mir gedacht ich
mache etwas am oberrhein und diesen
zuckersirup gibt es auch in anderen
geschmäckern ich habe ja auch in meinem
cocktail video gezeigt dass ich diesen
trend arisierung habt sowas könnte
annehmen oder ich besuche
ich stand da nicht mehr original
milchschnitte aber ein bisschen kokos
geschmack hätten wir jetzt gerne mit
drin
und ihr könnt natürlich wenn ihr möchtet
etwas honig nehmen
das lassen wir jetzt weg weil ich honig
eben kuchen ehrlich gesagt nicht so
macht er nur aufs brot und das ebenso
wie gesagt auch unternehmen und sogar
sehr gut weil ich jetzt so etwas
unternehmen aber das müsst ihr selbst ab
schlucken wie süß haben berichtet und
könnt ihr dann auch probieren nichts
kommt die sahne einfach in die
rührschüssel und hier gebe ich jetzt wie
gesagt von diesem sehr gut mit dazu ich
mach mal so zwei esslöffel das dürfte
etwa 40 millimeter sein
und da gebe ich jetzt auch ein spritzer
von diesem kokosnuss wetter zu können
natürlich weglassen
da kommt jetzt der spritzschutz drauf
und das werde ich jetzt bei höchster
stufe verrühren und so etwa 30 sekunden
gebe ich hier durch diese öffnungen das
sommerbad pulver mit dazu und das ist so
fest schlagen wir eben eine feste creme
habt
das beste sind die creme und so finde
ich so richtig super und an der stelle
könnte das jetzt abschmecken und
probieren ob es genug ist oder eben noch
ein bisschen ausgeruht mir dazu geben
ich habe hier meine den teig platte und
die nehme ich jetzt einmal von diesem
tuch unter dazu gebe ich sie auf meinen
tanten retter und schon dreht ist
einfach um
und jetzt kommt wieder meinen toten
tiger zum einsatz und zwar wird jetzt
die katze halbiert und das werden
praktisch so zwölf teile und dazu lege
ich das jetzt einfach drauf wieder mit
der schrift 24 nach oben drückt es kurz
um einfach die stellen zu markieren wo
ich gleich schneiden muss und deshalb
wäre ich jetzt hier und jetzt ich habe
jetzt hier richtig schön die stellen
markiert das heißt dieser torten tyler
ist perfekt für tiramisu für donauwelle
für irgendwie nun stehe ich also für
alle schnitten auch wenn man eine banane
schnitte alles was man eben schöne
gleichmäßige teile teilen möchte und
damit es später sich leichter schneiden
lässt werde ich jetzt die obere platte
einmal auseinander schneiden damit ich
später beim schneiden keine probleme
bekommen
und jetzt gebe ich hier meine creme
drauf wenn ihr hier jetzt natürlich
doppelte menge macht und zwei platten
backt dann könnt ihr das ganze auch mit
einem verstellbaren bank kamen nochmal
um rannten
das ist ein einfacher dann hättet ihr
jetzt hier außenrum den bug haben aber
der ball kam ist es nicht klein genug
für diese menge und um den rand jetzt
hier richtig schön zu machen nehme ich
jetzt hier eine zeitkarte und setzt die
hier an und dann kann ich hier schön bis
zum rand streichen
dann streiche ich hier nochmal drüber
das ist richtig schön glatt wird und
hier könnte natürlich auch wenn ihr
wollt ein paar schokostreusel
einarbeiten oder verdrückte oreo kekse
oder oder oder
so alles was ihr wollt jetzt setzt sich
hier die einzelnen platten wieder drauf
jetzt könnte hier gerade mit den rand
sauber ab 10 jetzt müssen die schnitten
nur noch geschnitten werden
das macht haben wir schon so
und dann zwischendurch das messer immer
wieder sauber machen
so können teure milchschnitten im
prinzip auch gleich sanieren
ihr könnt sie natürlich auch etwas kühl
stellen vorher was ich auch ganz gut
finde
ich sehe jetzt die fertigen
milchschnitten aus wir haben sie auch
schon probiert die sind richtig lecker
wir finden aber dass die richtig gut
schmecken wenn sie kalt sind also ihr
solltet euch vielleicht sogar überlegen
die entweder ganz lange im kühlschrank
zu stellen oder sie sogar vielleicht
eine halbe stunde ins gefrierfach zu
stellen weil wenn man nämlich rein weist
oder also ich finds dass es um menschen
wieder hand geht wenn man weiß dann
quillt an der seite die sau raus und ich
finde es eben bessere die schwester wäre
also das sieht man jetzt ja auch schon
aber diesen richtig richtig lecker und
ich hoffe natürlich dass euch dieses
rezept gefällt und das ist mal
ausprobiert wie gesagt wer das jetzt so
eine neue kategorie bei mir und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr ein paar
namensvorschläge für mich habt also für
diese gekaufte und selbst gemachte sache
und da könnt ihr natürlich auch ideen
und wünsche schicken also wenn ihr jetzt
sagt sally zeigt mir wie man selbst oreo
kekse machen kann zum beispiel da habe
ich nämlich auch schon eine ganz tolle
idee man könnte mir das sachen schicken
oder ich versuchte es als selbst
kreiertes rezepten umzusetzen
ich habe aber auch noch eine andere
kategorie die ich machen möchte
abgesehen von den ganzen motiv trocken
die jetzt alle noch kommen möchte ich so
eine kategorie in der ich einfach ganz
klassischer torten und so ganz
klassisches gefällt macht wie zum
beispiel donau um eine schwarzwälder
kirschtorte und ebenso dieses ganz
klassische und was ihr da vielleicht
auch noch eine idee hat wie wir das
benennen könnten
ich habe die idee gehabt vielleicht sei
dies classics auf leicht fällt euch da
noch was besseres dazu ein
da würde ich mich darüber freuen dieses
rezept gibt es natürlich auch zum
nachlesen auf meinem blog den link setzt
sich wieder unten nehmen die infobox
sein müsste einmal antreten und sagen
schon drauf und in dieser info box
findet ihr nicht nur den link zum rezept
sondern auch zu den ganzen produkten und
ich würde mich jetzt natürlich auch
darüber freuen wenn ihr
bewertung für dieses video abgibt und
mir einen kommentar rast und ist gerne
mit euren freunden teilt bis bald